- All right, we're back.
With sold out shows in
both Korea and the US,
our next guest are quickly becoming
one of the most successful
K-pop bands out there.
They recently did a
collaboration with Pink Sweats
and put out their fifth
mini album called "SET IN."
Now performing their single "Back Down",
making their US TV debut,
give it up for P1Harmony.
(audience cheers)
- [P1Harmony] Plus everything.
Hello, we are P1Harmony.
- We are so excited to be on
"The Kelly Clarkson Show".
- We have a special
performance for you today.
- We're debuting our
new single "Back Down"
from our fifth mini
album "HARMONY : SET IN"
out everywhere tomorrow.
- We hope you'll love it.
Enjoy.
- [P1Harmony] Thank you.
♪ Yeah, bring it on ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Look at that ♪
(sings in Korean)
♪ Hit back, hit, hit back ♪
♪ You can't see me in the sky ♪
♪ Oh ♪
(sings in Korean)
♪ Oh boy ♪
♪ We don't need, we don't
need second chances ♪
♪ We don't care, we ain't scared anymore ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
(sings in Korean)
♪ Together ♪
♪ Whoever ♪
♪ So what you waiting for ♪
♪ Back down ♪
(sings in Korean)
♪ Ready back down ♪
♪ Go steady, back down ♪
♪ You know that we're never gonna ♪
♪ Ra, ta, ta, ta ♪
♪ Back down ♪
♪ Go get it, back down ♪
♪ Shut the don't worry, back down ♪
♪ You know that we never gonna ♪
♪ Ra, ta, ta, ta, back down ♪
♪ Ring, ting, ting ♪
♪ Ting, ting, ting (sings in Korean) ♪
♪ Pray for me I'm gonna do something big ♪
♪ Ting, ting, ting ♪
(sings in Korean)
♪ Be what ♪
♪ Whoa oh ♪
(sings in Korean)
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Whoa ♪
♪ We don't need, we don't
need second chances ♪
♪ No, no, no, no ♪
♪ We don't care, we ain't scared anymore ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
(sings in Korean)
♪ Together ♪
♪ Whatever ♪
♪ So what you waiting for ♪
♪ What you waiting for ♪
♪ Back down ♪
(sings in Korean)
♪ Ready back down ♪
♪ Go steady, back down ♪
♪ You know that we never gonna ♪
♪ Ra, ta, ta, ta ♪
♪ Come on, back down ♪
♪ Go get it, back down ♪
♪ Shut the don't worry, back down ♪
♪ You know that we never gonna ♪
♪ Ra, ta, ta, ta, back down ♪
♪ Stand up, stand up ♪
♪ Then put your hands up ♪
(sings in Korean)
♪ When you're falling back down ♪
♪ Back down, back down, let's get it ♪
♪ Stand up, stand up ♪
♪ Then put your hands up ♪
(sings in Korean)
♪ Get up when you're falling
back down, down, down ♪
(Keeho laughs)
- Time to change it now.
♪ Back down ♪
(sings in Korean)
♪ Ready back down, back down ♪
♪ Go steady, back down, back down ♪
♪ You know that we never gonna ♪
♪ Ra, ta, ta, ta ♪
♪ Back down ♪
♪ Gotta go get it, back down ♪
♪ Shut the don't worry, back down ♪
♪ You know that we never gonna ♪
♪ Ra, ta, ta, ta ♪
♪ Back down, yeah ♪
(audience cheers)
- One more time for P1Harmony, everybody.
Their new mini album
"SET IN" drops tomorrow.
Get it wherever you get your music.